hello everyone and welcome to another
nice game from the Greinke chess classic
2019 tournament it's a game from round 7
world champion Magnus Carlsen faces his
old rival 11 Oregon and we don't have
any nice footage or photos from this run
as the game ended rather quickly but we
will be showing more games from this
round and then we're gonna check out if
we do have some nice footage from the
Greinke just classic video team and well
check out the standings as well but I
did prepare just you know so we have
something in their previous encounters
as you can see Magnus Carlsen beat 11
Aragon 16 to 7 with 35 draws so they've
played a lot of times against each other
cross and well won twice more than twice
as many games against eleven so an
excellent opportunity for 11 to at least
you know lower the difference and also
we can check out including rapid and/or
exhibition games
Magnus cross and beat 11 Aragon 30 to 20
with 57 draws so it's the the difference
is less in in fast time controls but in
classical across and does have the upper
hand
so it's interesting how 11 will deal
with this with the black pieces so let's
check it out
Carlson has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 and well by now you
already know what this means
we have c4 e6 Knight to f3 and d5 if
you're following games on this channel
from any modern championship and well
capablanca saga then I'm sure you all
are a masters of the Queens gambit
declined by now
nice to see 3 and here we have d
captures in c4 waiting before capturing
we have E 4 by Carlsen as the center is
now his for the taking and b4 with
Bishop to g5 and c5 now this is a well
known line that has been played many
times Bishop captures on c4 c captures d
Knight captures on d4 and now Bishop
captures on c3 pawn captures on c3 and
now Queen to a5 and we can say that it's
it is as of this moment that the game
really begins this game had this
happen a lot of times and it's available
in the database in approximately 600 or
more games and a lot of MOS have been
played here a bunch of b5 check has been
played here as you have to be careful
the queen is attacking the bishop on g5
so Bishop to b5 check was played here
nice to b5 was played here blocking the
Queen's attack to the bishop and also a
knife from b5 guards the c3 pawn and
also just Bishop captures and f6 was
played allowing Queen captures and c3
with the check but here cross and just
goes back with the Bishop Bishop d2
Queen no longer attacks the bishop
bishop guards the c3 pawn and it's all
ready for a move 10 that we have a
completely new game on our hands with
cost and going to Bishop to b2 and now
Aragon has to decide what to do here
does he wanna go for this well fancy
line Knight captures only 4 will he grab
the pawn and allow Queen g4 which then
the Queen attacks the night and also
goes for the g7 pawn and then you with
Knight capture some d2 Queen captures
and g7 and it's a really crazy position
where white should have the upper hand
so 11 isn't interested in this after
Bishop to d2 he first castles to safety
and now cross and just goes Queen e2 we
developed the queen guards d4 pawn with
E 5 attacking cousins Knight nice to be
3 pushing the Queen back Queen to c7 and
now crossing just castles and here
Bishop to g4
if might think but why Bishop to g4 I
mean sure you're baiting f3 but cross
and even wants to play f3 he wants the
strength in the e4 pawn but this is
Oregon's idea after f3
he went rook the c8 and now with a
double attack against the bishop here
hoping for captures and captures Carlsen
of course isn't interested with the
shift to d5 getting the bishop out of
the way and now Knight captures on d5 e
captures on d5 and now you could go back
with Bishop to d7 but with the pawn
controlling the c6 square you don't
really have a good choice for developing
this night so here our gang goes Bishop
to age 5 and it is a funny square for
this Bishop sure it pins this pawn but
other than that not really an impressive
piece and ok here Carlson takes this
opportunity to further strengthen his
position
the d5 point is a very nice past porn
but you also have to strengthen it so
here see for a very nice move because
the pond is the pond is immune to
capture if Queen captures on c4 just
rook c1 and white wins the game now you
either lose the Queen or you capture
white queen and now it's mate in one
group captures on CA so an excellent
strengthening move by Carlsen so you
cannot capture it Knight to d7 is played
by Aragon and I'll just look F to c1 in
an interview after the game cross and
said that he even thought about rook a
c1 but he thought that the a rook
belongs to the a file as black might
have some counter play with a five and a
four
so b6 by by 11 with a four by Carlson in
the now a five with Queen to f2 now with
ideas of piling up against the b6 pawn
it's a backwards pawn it's a weak point
and it will be the well the object of
attack for for the rest of the game
Queen to b6 by Aragon and now push up
the e3 not with a double attack against
this point so far it's protected by the
Queen end by the night but if any of the
rooks join the attack it will be
somewhat hard to defend it bush of the
g6 finally the bishop gets away from
this nasty h5 square Peter like oh who
is an official commentator with young
Gustafson on chess 24 mentioned that he
he's familiar with position is similar
to these where black has this set up but
with this Bishop on b7 and this is very
nice but it's a really really weird with
the bishop on on h5 but okay brush up to
g6 now the bishop is on a very nice
diagonal and Queen back to d2 we have f6
by black strengthening the e5 pawn and
now Queen to be two again Reema nuvaring
the Queen putting pressure against the
b6 pawn we have looked the c7 now
preparing to bring the other look into
the game and now we have nice to d2
just opening up the Queen's attack
towards the pawn and also the night is
now guarding the c4 pawn twice we have
night to c5 after the game 11 said that
he didn't really enjoy this night to see
five move but it's I mean it's not a bad
move and there's it's hard to find a
better one
so tonight to see five we have Queen to
a three taking advantage of the Knights
position and c5 the Queen on d6 is
undefended
so here 11 goes rook to d8 the queen is
now defended and here rook the c3 just a
very nice rook lift as it guards the d3
squares square twice so no nice DT
reaction will be possible and here black
it's very hard for black to find the
move and even though it's only moved 26
11 is a very very long time for the last
15 moves before time control 11 was
about a minute and a half on the clock
and here it's hard to say what the play
engines recommendations go rook to b7
and just play it playing a passive
position waiting for whites to make a
move but 11 with such little time on the
clock isn't interested in making passive
moves he went for the active idea he
goes f5 he wants to push efore and okay
we've looked to be won by Carson
preparing for efore and Levin pushes it
nonetheless with E 4 F captures only 4 F
captures on e4 and now cross in place
Bishop captures on c5 so basically white
is winning a pawn and black will not
have all that much to show for it
rook captures on c5 and now Knight
captures on e4 wouldn't an attack on the
Queen Queen to e5 with a double attack
against the night and also pressuring
the rook here just rips e2 e3
doubling up on the e-file now and now 11
goes back we could look C to c8 now with
with greater control of the of the last
rank and here you could go for something
like Knights to d2 immediately which is
the plan you want to take care of the c4
pawn but then Queen to d4 will be
somewhat of a nuisance
so here cross and just goes h3 gives
this King some more breathing space
waits for black to make a move and here
if you go route captures now if you try
and grab the phone again 92 just attacks
the pawn and the Queen you will lose
material here and the white will have a
winning position
so after h3 we have Queen to c7 going
back
the Queen and now comes Knight to d2 so
this is basically due to 11 active plan
would f-5e 4 he now has to defend this
game where he is down a pawn and the
Carson has a past deep on and black
really does not have all that many
active moves
we have rook to e8 and here cross and
could trade down it's a pretty much a
force line after characters captures
captures captures now you can take
advantage of this a weird position of
the bishop here and go for d6 first you
attack the Queen and after Queen to d7
blocking now Queen to III and now the
Queen cannot capture here as well the
bishop on it would not be defended so
you would go for Queen captures on a for
Queen captures and b6 and now after
Queen D 1 check Knights to f1 and h6 you
would get this position where across and
is still up upon he has two connected
passed pawns well they're not yet
connected but after c5 did they will be
but black also has a outside pass pawn
so it would be it would be a race where
white would be better but Crossin
doesn't like this with but one of the
reasons why across and Pro might not
have gone for this is because 11 is
still one minute on the clock he's
playing on increment and here cross and
just doesn't want to allow him to have
only one move to play which is a forced
line so he just goes rook to e7 forces
him to take once as the queen is under
attack we have Queen captures rook
captures and now again very little time
on the clock Levin has to decide what to
do best
for black here would be Queen to f4 but
it's still not giving all that much ESC
it attacks the night here on d2 but just
Queen to c3 defends the night and also
threatens checkmate here so you have to
block checkmate with Bishop to f7 and
then after Queen to e3 defending the
knight offering a queen trade you'd get
captures captures and white would again
have well have a really superior end
game if not winning due to the due to
white being a pawn black doesn't really
have any good contra play and it's just
a much better position for white the b6
point is very weak most likely white
will very quickly win both the bonds on
the Queen side so after rook captures on
e7
Aaron and went for Queen to d8 and the
now comes Queen to III again pressuring
black thing you don't really want to
leave the the back rank I'm gonna go
something like Queen e5 Queen captures
and g7 and it will be a very difficult
position to defend so rook the c7 11
wants the trade rooks but now just Queen
a sorry rook to e6 as there is a double
attack against the b6 pawn and there's
no good way to defend it here rook to c5
was played blocking the Queen's attack
towards the b6 pawn but here Carson just
played Queen to b3 and now there is no
more there are no more ways to defend
the b6 pawn you are already up a pawn
you will win a second one and it was in
this position unmoved 38 that 11 aragon
resigns the game without even reaching
time control and move 40 and he had I
believe well he got some time on the
increment he finished a game I believe
with a minute and a half on the clock
but still in in a very difficult
position and he was really suffering for
the for the last 20 moves yeah here
pretty much anything you do let's say
well 5 attack the rook just Queen
captures here attacks the Queen attacks
the rook you would have to trade and
after captures captures now you're just
up 2 points which is a lot and if you
try something let's say but should be 3
to win the pond just d6 the pawn will
become a queen if Bishop f5 trying to
prevent the point from going forward
let's say Ruby 5 you force a trade here
otherwise you're gonna lose the bishop
so after captures captures now black has
to take care of - passed pawns and well
that's simply not possible white is
completely winning here sir
after this Queen to b3 Aragon resigned
and yet another victory for Magnus
Carlsen who is after seven rounds of
disagreeing HS classic 2019 in five and
a half out of seven we're not going to
discuss the other results from drunk as
I will definitely be showing another
game from this round and we're gonna
then check out the standings and perhaps
show some nice footage if the
Greinke just classic video team well
compliments us with with such footage
but yeah as usual you can check or in
the description the first two links will
be either an interview with one of the
players also or I will always update the
links in the description so you can
enjoy more content from the grand each
as classic video team and impressions
from the previous round will also
always be there so do check that out as
well I would like to thank David Mackey
John Edwards son Xavier Victoria Lucas
knot and Harry Potter for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully much with some more
interesting content continuing this saga
continuing the commerce saga continuing
the capablanca saga and of course
checking up on your suggestions as usual
yeah once again I do hope you enjoyed it
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Saturday